Zoink's we should go over there. Oh *Ding*
Jinkies we should wander this away. *Ding* Oh, Mama mia! Here I go again! Ah ah!
Here is your veggies and salad to eat. Here's the crack cocaine.
You're doing good, you're doing good.
You have any idea, how fast you were going? I'll give you a hint
it's somewhere between stopped and really fast. *Laughter*
Need to get this barrel ready. Our daughter, she's turning 3,
We're gonna put her in and send her down on her way.
Doctor I know they're large breast implants but I think I've got them. Are you sure? I've got them
This is a pretty good first date, I don't know about you.
Can you clean up a little bit of the blood? Which way are we going? I'M PRETTY SURE YOUR GOING TO BE IN TROBLE FOR MOVING THE BODY!
We should get out of here, he's gonna kill us I think he's got a hamster. *Ding*  Look! I think he's gotta dildo..?
Hey guys
Hope you enjoyed that. That's a little preview the show that we have in store for you on the tour. All that footage actually is
from our June shows when we went on that four city run.
And I know a lot of you guys were like eh, four cities. That's not a tour
That's like a vacation between states
And we know and the reason that we did such a small set of that was because we wanted to make sure that this show
was actually good.
Because we we do a lot more than just a meet-and-greet or just Let's Plays
And when we all got together
And we thought about this project we wanted it to be a show
That even if you weren't a fan of my channel, or a fan of any of our videos
You could still enjoy the show objectively because it combines like music, improv,
dancing, audience participation- we, we
wanted to reinforce this idea that the show is different every time you see it, and it may not be drastically different
but with improv and the choices that you guys make during the show
It can go a long way.
So if you want to see where the show is gonna be check out
Markiplier.com or check out the link in the description, goes the same place,
Markiplier.com you'll see all of the different cities that we're going to, we're going to hit East Coast
We're gonna hit West Coast, a lot of the Midwest, we're gonna do a lot of that
But also, we're gonna go to Europe hooray!
We don't have a ton of venues in Europe, we got about seven or eight,
But it still should be a ton of fun and it'll be so exciting especially for us that we travel for conventions
But we've never traveled out for a tour like this where everything rides on our performance
But I couldn't be happier with where the show is
and I couldn't be more grateful that you guys are joining us on this little adventure that we got going on so check out the
Dates and check out the link down there. The tickets will go on sale 9 a.m.
Pacific Standard Time tomorrow, which is September 7th and 9:00 a.m.. Pacific Standard Time is?
The people in the comments should be able to help you figure out what your time zone means for 9:00 a.m.
Pacific Standard Time, but I also wanted to mention
There's a VIP
component to this
The venues like require you to have a certain number of seats are that our VIP or something and I wanted to do something
Special for for people that did want to get something like that. I wanted an experience so for this particular run
for all of these shows
Before the main show starts not only will the VIP get in early
But I will be doing an acoustical cover set. I will be playing my guitar, and I will be singing songs
And I promise they're not all gonna be Ed Sheeran, and well, I mean there's there might be some Ed Sheeran
I can't stop myself
I love the boy too much, but yeah, it's the first time that I'll be performing musically in that capacity since
marching band in high school.
And I wasn't even singing then man, if I could play the trumpet and sing at the same time that'd be amazing
but yeah, I- I-
I've been practicing a lot and I'm to the point where I'm really happy with my music and my singing ability
Which which was never like, like I- I didn't even know if I was going to do that
But I feel pretty good about it
And it's gonna be a smaller setting so it should be a nice little intimate moment where I can
Perform for you guys in a way that I've never performed before and I think that's really cool.
So those tickets go on sale tomorrow as well, all of it is available through the link in the description below or go straight to
Markiplier.com and find out all the info that you need once again tickets go on sale September 7th 9 a.m.
Pacific Standard Time, check it out then and check it out there.
And thank you everybody so much for watching if you were at one of our shows let people know down in the comments
What you think of it, and thanks again for watching and as always I will see you in the next video
Bye bye! :D